hasta el momento el cerco de soyapango
esta ciudad denominada la industrial de
El Salvador ronda unas 40 horas se han
identificado una docena de pandilleros y
se ha capturado varios de ellos de
acuerdo con publicaciones de la Policía
Nacional salvadoreña la estrategia de
este cerco con Diez mil efectivos es la
de peinar el perímetro de este municipio
de El Salvador recorrer Colonia por
Colonia casa por casa hasta dar con el
paradero de todos los pandilleros que
allí se resguarden y aquellos que
quieran escapar no puedan hacerlo porque
todos los accesos de la ciudad tanto de
entrada como de salida están cercados
por la policía y los militares la
estrategia este domingo De hecho hubo
muestras de agradecimiento por parte de
la población hacia los militares se les
cocinó una olla de mariscos en una
cancha de polideportivo muchos de ellos
también se dieron a la tarea de pintar
Borrar todos los grafitis alusivos a las
pandillas Mara Salvatrucha 13 y barrio
18 y también otras personas pues se han
sentido atemorizadas por ver tanta
presencia militar Lo cierto es que este
municipio soyapango por años ha sido uno
de los más peligrosos que ha refugiado a
los pandilleros y desde donde de acuerdo
con inteligencias salvadoreña se han
planeado actos criminales ahora bien con
este cerco a soyapango se cumpliría la
quinta fase del plan de control
territorial de nayib bukele en el marco
del régimen de excepción que recordemos
comenzó el pasado marzo que hasta por lo
pronto terminaría a este mediados de
diciembre según nayib bukele no le hará
no le pasará nada a ningún ciudadano
honrado pero muchas organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos denuncian que durante
estos operativos si se violan los
derechos humanos de personas que no
tienen nada que ver con las pandillas